don't worry i can honestly senator  honestly it is about our truth 90  minutes before the vice presidential  debate even got started the GOP  mistakenly tweeted and posted an article  saying that Mike Pence had clearly one  that tells you about everything you  needed to know about tonight's debate  and you didn't need to watch it what we  need more than ever in American politics  are not politicians who simply talk over  each other and try to add scripted  one-liners that would have been tired in  a 90s sitcom do you want your hired  president in Hillary Clinton already one  of your fired president and Donald Trump  we need different points of view and we  need more voices on this stage and if we  don't get that it's not going to get any  better than this you've whipped out that  Mexican thing again for reason TV I'm  Nick Gillespie